the last time bread caused this much
distraction kanye west Sunday service
Kim told me her husband's message is
resonating for him it started off as
something that was really healing I
think that's just so amazing him
recently needed healing after getting
this diagnosis kind of get this little
depression of okay what are all the
possibilities that can happen what's my
life gonna look like I really had to get
myself together because I do have kids
I'm on a medication now so everything
seems to be fine for right now
the reality star moms in full work mode
launching a makeup collaboration with
model Vinnie Harlow for k'kaw beauty she
knew exactly what she wanted palette
wise color wise it made my job really
easy it's something that I never could
have even dreamt of but could Kim's next
collab be with Tori Spelling and Jennie
Garth we were thinking about Kim K for
your lawyer but they said they would
love for season two of Beverly Hills
90210 to have you on as Tori's employer
stop yes I wish to be are you there some
of that seriously I'm there
[Applause]
you